are you still close with jennifer and
liam like when was the last
yeah guys talked i i actually i saw
i saw jen um during quarantine
big news for you to celebrate because
the hunger games franchise is coming to
streaming
on tuesday what's the last time that you
watched those movies uh well actually
i've always seen each of them one time
and it was at the first premiere of each
of them i have not gone back and watched
them
uh which is they're good movies i mean i
i know that's the thing they're good
movies but also i'm in them
and so that's that's where i run to the
problem is i don't want to see myself on
the screen
um it's uh it's it's hard but honestly
i think enough time has passed i think
that i'm i've grown as a person
enough in a way to be able to watch them
with a step removed
and forgive myself for anything i don't
like um
and maybe just maybe just enjoy the film
so i'm i'm really happy they're
streaming though now
uh on 2b and it's free which i think is
really cool what is the most
surreal moment you have of that time
kind of looking back i mean the first
one premiered in 2012
the final one i think came out about
five years ago
i mean i guess the whole thing is
surreal um you know i remember actually
before we even
before we even stepped foot on set to
start shooting
um they held like a fan event in l.a
at like a mall or something and uh i
remember
me jen and liam it was like the first
time they were like introducing all the
cast to the fans
and we were sitting up in this room like
hair makeup or whatever and you could
there's like a window and you could look
out and see the fan area with
the stage and there were so many people
and they didn't even know if the movies
were going to be good they didn't even
know if they were going to like us or
not but it was just
like they loved the series of books so
much that they wanted to be a part of
like the
the movie process um and that was really
surreal and kind of the first moment of
what is this like what world are we
stepping into do you still
think that katniss and peta should have
ended up together
yes yes yes i do i do i think you know i
mean i think look
uh life is complicated love is
complicated
um katniss was really busy dealing with
a revolution to be
too concerned with these boys and uh
she was too busy trying to fight for
justice and freedom um but ultimately i
know that uh
that peta's love for katniss was uh
extremely
profound and deep and and caring and and
vice versa so
i'm happy to end up together i want to
show you something this is
okay first hunger games junket i've
definitely never been part of something
that had so much hype before we even
started uh shooting the first frame in
the movie let alone
now it's about to come out um it's
exciting and it's slightly you know
nerve-wracking from day one
liam and jennifer and i hit it off right
away i think that we kind of formed this
little group because we were sort of in
it all
of all of us together um and we were
like going to walmart
and like random little adventures before
we even started shooting so we
we bonded quite heavily for sure oh man
thank you
to watch that it's so funny it takes me
right back
i remember that trip to walmart
perfectly it was in asheville north
carolina
liam was like oh what's a walmart night
and we're like oh we're gonna show you
what
because jen's from kentucky i'm from
kentucky so it's like walmart was the
place to go
liam know what a walmart was he had
never experienced it he may have been
playing
dumb australian i don't know what he was
doing he was being leo and
uh and so yeah we went to walmart and
you know we went down to like a creek
and went like crawdad
fishing and we had a leech i had a leech
stuck to my hand and jen lost her mind
and
it was just yeah i i i'm like i can
transport directly back to that hole
that whole time it's crazy
that's amazing are you still close with
jennifer
and liam like when was the last yeah
guys talked
i i actually i saw i saw jen um during
quarantine we got to have
dinner together toward the end i guess
it was like
mid-summer maybe we had a a nice
socially distanced dinner together
um which is good to catch up with her
because she's been off living her life
in other places all over the world
um and i saw liam i think towards the
end of last year but then this year i
think he's been off in australia
um so i haven't gotten to see him yet
but we we we catch up every time we can
um i got to see woody not too long ago
too so it's
it's it's good no matter how much time
passes once we re
like see each other again it's just
instantly you know right back to where
it was
when you look at where your career has
gone where jen's career and liam's
career has all gone i mean what is it
like for you to sort of see how you guys
have all
kind of exploded and come into your own
path it's great i mean we all knew
you know from the beginning that that
jen was uh was
destined for for greatness you know she
is so such a special
everything about her and as a
performance as a person is everything
um you know so so we all we i remember
when she got
nominated for an oscar we were actually
shooting and everyone was just
so excited we're so proud and also kind
of like of course
like of course of course um so it's been
great just to see everyone's you know
different paths and trajectories and i
think like as an actor kind of when you
do
something like the hunger games it is
difficult to
to break out of that and it's difficult
to not get boxed in and
and you know for me i've been very
cautious about doing anything that i i
thought was
wasn't what i wanted to be doing and you
know like maybe there was a
a set path that i could have sort of
followed that would have
led me to a different place but that's
not what i wanted to be and
and peta always said don't become a
peace in their game and so for me i was
always very
steadfast and i'd rather not work and
wait until i can find kind of
the kind of actor and the kind of
projects that i that i wanna that i
wanna be and wanna do
there is um a hunger games prequel that
was greenlit and i know that it takes
place
pre-peta time um what did you think of
that news first of all
i think it's great i mean i think like i
don't know anything about it uh like
story-wise but if it has to do with
understanding how we got to the world of
the hunger games then i think that's
gonna be super interesting i would like
peter to be in it because i would like
to
be with these people again and work work
more in that world um
i was going to ask you like would you
revisit the role of peta if there was a
way for them to shoot like fast forwards
for sure 100 100 yeah it'd be great i i
love that whole cast crew
if they can get some of the same people
involved no question